Hello, my name is Zisl Slepovitch
and I'm musician-in-residence at Yale
University's Fortunoff Video Archive for
Holocaust Testimonies.
This video series is designed as a companion
to our album Where Is Our Homeland,
which is the first volume in the archive's
ongoing effort to present songs
and poems performed by survivors in
testimonies given to the Fortunoff Archive
over the last 40 years.
You can learn more about the project on the
archive's website,
songsfromtestimonies.org.
Where Is Our Homeland?
Songs from Testimonies.
Volume One was recorded in 2019
by the Zisl Slepovitch Ensemble featuring
renowned singer Sasha Lurje, Craig
Judelman on the violin, Joshua Camp
on the accordion, keyboards and guitar,
Dmitry Ishenko on the bass, and myself
on woodwinds.
The songs in this
collection differ vastly in
terms of style, socia and historical
background, language and many other
aspects, but collectively they
create a multidimensional picture of Jewish
life before and during World War
II.
Jack M was one of the
wonderful folk singers who had a tremendous
memory, and he remembered a lot
of the pre-war repertoire
coming from the weddings, from
his home, from the army,
from the street, from the school.
And his testimony not only
reveals his personal experience
during the Holocaust, but it really
gives us a really deep insight
into what Jewish Polish
culture was before the war.
One of the songs that Jack sang
on the testimony is "Badkhen
Song." The badkhen was a Wedding
Jester, a figure that was really
instrumental in the Ashkenazic
Jewish wedding beginning in 1400s
and through the 20th century.
As a boy, Jack remembered two badkhonen,
which is a plural of a Badkhen,
in his small town of Szydlowiec.
One was a Hasidic religious person.
The other was more of a secular
badkhen.
And that song
was arranged by us, by the
Zisl Slepovitch Ensemble and performed
on the album Where Is Our Homeland
with the wonderful soloist singer Sasha
Lurje.
So we decided to open it with
the Doina, which is a semi improvisatory
instrumental composition.
This particular Doina came
from the collection of Moisey Beregovskiy,
a notable Ukrainian-Jewish Soviet
ethnographer, who captured along
with Sofia Magid, another
musicologist from
Leningrad, St. Petersburg,
the last moments of the
Old World pre-war Jewish tradition
in Belarus and Ukraine.
So although Jack came from Poland,
but opening the composition with a Doina
makes it really a lifelike
music making situation.
The song is followed by the freylekhs tune.
The mocking street song
was "Vos bistu ketsele
baroygez." Why are you so
angry, honey?
The biggest kick off in a wedding
was the marshelik.
A marshelik was out of this
world, he was the entertainer.
He was the announcer of the
[INAUDIBLE]. They didn't give no money,
just presents for stay.
In the wedding [? party ?].
When he got to entertain them in
dates, first we had two.
One was a religious guy
and the other one was hartsveytik.
Worldly, non-religious, or worldly.
Yeah, yeah.
The religious guy, he made it
in Hasidic.
He gave them a Hasidic song.
Eh, eh, keyn vitsin.
No, no jokes at all.
[INAUDIBLE]
Papa says to Shmelke:
"Don't be such a numbskull!
Heed to your old father.
And restrain your anger with him."
He can't eat,
He can't sleep,
For it's
written in the Torah,
Thus speaketh our creator:
"A Jew mustn't be alone.
He must have a wife,
Who can later bury him.
A Jew mustn't be alone."
Papa says to Shmelke:
"Don't be such a numbskull!
Heed to your old father.
And restrain your anger with him."
He can't eat,
He can't sleep,
For it's
written in the Torah,
Thus speaketh our creator:
"A Jew mustn't be alone.
He must have a wife,
Who can later bury him.
A Jew mustn’t be alone."
For it's written in the Torah,
Thus speaketh our creator:
"A Jew mustn’t be alone.
He must have a wife,
Who can later bury him.
A Jew mustn't be alone."
The song of the marshelik,
the badkhen, which is
described as the biggest kick in a
wedding.
What's the context?
What's, what's going on here?
Well, it's, it's a wedding.
And we know a
wedding has a groom and a bride and
the family and the
officiator, maybe a rabbi.
Friends.
Maybe some poor people are
being invited as well, depending
on how wealthy the family is.
And there's one person who kind
of provides the glue, the continuity,
and that's the marshelik, the
badkhen.
And the role of the badkhen
or the marshelik, as Jack
M. remembers him,
is to both entertain
and also instruct and keep
things moving.
So there are
two of these marsheliks
that, that Jack remembers from his
growing up in pre-war
Eastern Europe.
One of them was a religious guy
who was a Hasid and did things
sort of by the book straight.
And the other one he describes as
hartsveytik. That means it was already a
heartache.
And that
probably means that his parents
were caused a lot of heartache by his
straying from the path of religious
observance.
But on the other hand, it gave him that
point of view that made him a great
entertainer because he took things with
a grain of salt and he knew how to make
clever double entendres and
jokes.
And it was very
entertaining to the point that
Jack remembers him as
providing the biggest kick in a wedding.
So.
In today's weddings, I think
we would
place this somewhere in
the area of a toast to
the couple, which sometimes turns
into a roast because
the family and friends who are celebrating
the marriage with the
man and wife to be, or wife and
wife, or man and man,
are often
making little inside jokes and referring
to old nicknames that are
a little embarrassing but not too
embarrassing.
And that's the spirit
of the marshelik who
is trying to lighten
the mood and also keep things real,
and not leave it only
at the religious precepts that
his job is also partly to
impart to the couple.
So here we have a
marshelik who is addressing
only the male members of the wedding party.
This is before the groom
is taken to meet
the bride and proceed with the ceremony.
So this is all men, this is the
the groom and his father
principly, and
the other members of
the, male members of the
community and
the marshelik begins by
saying
[VOCALIZES]
to Shmelke.
That's the groom.
His dad says
[VOCALIZES].
Don't try to be a wise
guy, don't try to be,
play the fool.
Don't pretend that you
don't understand what's
going on.
That's what his dad is saying.
And then the marshelik continues,
[VOCALIZES].
Listen to what your old man is saying.
Horkh oys dayn foter Yankl dem alten.
[VOCALIZES].
And your anger at me
contain it.
Now just,
hold yourself back here.
Don't be angry with me, I'm just the
messenger.
Very interesting.
Why is the groom angry?
What's the anger about?
Class?
The anger is that
the groom is about to
lose his independence,
no longer going to be
a free, single
young person with no
responsibilities.
And, no, he's going
to have to become a
full fledged member of the
community, take on all the obligations
of marriage and
that's a scary transition,
as one he apparently
doesn't want to take on.
He's angry about it.
So the marshelik continues
to explain, "Er
ken nisht esn," [VOCALIZES].
He can't eat, [VOCALIZES],
he can't sleep.
He can't eat, he can't sleep, he's so
agitated.
This formulation is one that we find
in another
context of romantic songs,
a love song where,
for example, in "A Kholem,"
we hear, "Ikh es nisht, di trink nisht
ikh shlaf nisht durkh di nakht.
Wayl banken luba benk ikh
nakh dir nakh dir."
I can't eat, I can't sleep, I'm not
eating, sleeping, I'm
not sleeping through the
night. I can't eat.
I can't drink because I'm
longing for you, my love,
my sweetheart.
This is a different kind of not being
able to eat or sleep.
It's being upset and anxious,
the transition about to happen.
And what's causing the anxiety?
[VOCALIZES]. Because it's written,
[VOCALIZES], it's written
in the Torah and the sacred law,
[VOCALIZES]
so says our creator,
[VOCALIZES],
a Jew must not
remain alone, must not be alone.
[VOCALIZES], a wife
he has to take, he has to have
a wife.
And now comes the punchline:
[VOCALIZES].
Who will be able, the wife, right, will
be able later to bury him.
[VOCALIZES]
A Jew must not be alone.
So that's the precept.
And this
this sort of double entendre, "zol
im kenen shpeter bagrubn,"
literally means, "will they be
able to bury him,"
which is a bit like...getting
married and having children
so that you will have a kaddishel,
you will have someone who can
say Kaddish after you.
Uh.
Yes, if you get married, then
when you die, your partner will be able
to make sure that you are brought to
keyver-yisro'el, that you were buried
according to Jewish law,
but also, also
it means to vanquish,
if you, if you bury someone, it's
like on the battlefield here.
It's the battle of the sexes.
Where you bury someone
who means that you vanquished, then you
conquer them.
So it's
a kind of wisdom
and wisecrack rolled into one.
A seykhl khokhme,
un a khokhme, a piece of
wisdom, but also a wisecrack.
And this is, this is the way
of the Marshelik, who was entertaining,
but also fulfilling
his obligation to lay down
the law and make sure that
the participants of the wedding
understand what's, what's in store for
them and what they're getting into.
We have in
the literature, for example, Itzik Manger
writes about the badkhen, who
is in that case addressing
the bride. And this is another convention
of explaining
how sad this day
is for the bride, because like
the groom who was about to lose his
independence, the bride is about to lose
her beauty.
So we have, for example,
in that song that I'm thinking
of from Manger,
"A shaten dos lebn,"
life is a shadow.
"A shaten dos glick," and
happiness is a shadow.
"Di sheynkayt fergayt,"
beauty fades like the setting sun.
"Um komt nisht tsurik,"
and doesn't return.
"Azoy zagt dos badkhen,"
that's what the badkhen, the marshelik
says, "mit trerin
im blick," with tears
in his eyes.
So in that case, Itzik Manger is
painting a little
portrait of a different
moment in the ritual
where the badkhen is
addressing the bride and
the marshelik song that, that
Jack M. remembers from growing
up. It's the marshelik
having a little fun with reminding
the groom, "A
yidl tur nisht zayn alayn."
You know, you've got
to get married because a
Jew cannot be alone.